wir sind nicht ready dafür nee wir sind
eigentlich eigentlich sind wir nicht
ready dafür Leute ich hole ihn oder ich
glaube wir sollten hier einfach nicht zu
viel darüber sprechen weil sonst
hyperventiliere ich hmm
da ist er da ist er Leute ist das eine
schwere Geburt okay ich weiß nicht ob es
extra für mich ist aber hier ist einfach
schon eine Schneidematte drin
rutschfeste Zimmer zum Kneten und alles
andere
ist Sallys Produkte Katalog
das ist ein es ist ein eigener
Neckermann Katalog aber nein der ist das
nur mit Sally Produkten naja der was was
brauchst du eine Kinder Jeans Scherze
haben wir Buchstaben und Zahlen Stempel
gar kein problem we got you covered my
name ist ein bisschen älter als ich ne
und die hat so einen tollen Haaransatz
der riecht sogar fantastisch
das ist er wir haben einen Brief
gekriegt ich frage mich nur von wem ich
glaube es ist ein Liebesbrief oh nein
ist einfach nur falls man den
verschenken möchte meine Damen und
Herren ich präsentiere euch den Sally
Adventskalender
2022 das ist ein gottverdammter Koffer
und ich liebe es bevor ich 100 mal Sally
sage dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
außer dass mir Sally diesen Kalender
zugeschickt hat denn es war quasi
unmöglich einen zu erhalten der war so
schnell ausverkauft ist wundert mich
nicht weil der wird super sein ich weiß
es jetzt schon vielen Dank Sally dass du
mir das Vertrauen schenkst dafür stehe
ich mit meinem Namen dass ich ihn aus
also ich liebe dich ich liebe dich schon
lange
Fakten dieser Kalender ging für einen
stolzen Preis von
139,99 über die Ladentheke und ich
vermute dass er einen Warenwert von
149,99 hat weil der Preis
durchgestrichen wurde Ersparnis 10 € und
da ich vermute dass das eh alles Sallys
Produkte sind die machen wahrscheinlich
alle in diesem Katalog finden kann
werden wir heute auch keine Preise
rechnen denn es ist ja was anderes als
ein Daniela Katzenberger Barbara
Schöneberger Kalender wo Plätze verkauft
werden wo man gar nicht hin also ist
einfach einfacher ist Dinge für
günstiger zu bekommen also erstmal das
toll
toll toller Druck toll Gold gestanzt
love it okay ich weiß wir werden viel
Spaß damit haben let's go
[Musik]
ich habe ein Autogramm von Sally das
gebe ich gleich meiner Schwester hier
Alina kannst du haben in die Küche
hängen und dann hast du immer deine
Inspiration an der Wand hängt also seit
vielen Jahren wünschen sich meine
Zuschauer in schon einen Sally Kalender
so viel Sally wie möglich Sally war bis
jetzt aber noch nicht bereit dafür und
jetzt jetzt ist sie jetzt ist sie bereit
bis bald ich bin gekommen ich bin bereit
ja ganz genau kommen wir zum Design es
ist was neues so habe ich es noch nicht
gesehen und ihr wisst ich habe schon
sehr viele Adventskalender gesehen und
sprechen hier mit so Kunstlederband also
ich muss aufwenden jetzt hier so zu
loben aber ich bin jemand ich brauche
solche Sachen für immer über am Schrank
unterm Bett ich habe da immer irgendwo
meine Kisten und
Aufbewahrungsmöglichkeiten und das ist
wirklich tipptopp ja und dann haben wir
hier drin unsere Türchen davon lauter
Aufregung nicht irgendwas vergessen ach
ja hallo Leute willkommen zu Sallys Welt
wir packen jetzt Türchen Nummer eins aus
Türchen Nummer eins tolle trendige Farbe
wir haben hier ein Salbei schönes Design
mal was Neues es war so ganz toll sogar
die Öffnung ist anders ey die Spielen
nicht ne
natürlich der absolute Klassiker in
Türchen Nummer eins befindet sich das
Vanilleextrakt Bio Vanilleextrakt es ist
so verrückt stellt euch mal vor ich wäre
nur halb so fleißig wie Sally gewesen
und jetzt habe ich so überall Produkte
wo dann einfach mal war eine drauf steht
oder Vanessa ja kenne ich liebe dich
tolles erstes Türchen Nummer zwei in der
Nummer 2 befindet sich ich mache es auf
und sehe schon Sally willst du Mini
Spritzbeutel kann man in der
Weihnachtszeit gut gebrauchen ach so ja
dann ist es so eine Rolle und dann hast
du einfach ganz kleine Spritzbeutel drin
auch super praktisch für Lebkuchenhäuser
machen oder wie hier irgendein kleinen
Mist dekorieren und 10 % auf
spritzbeutelständer Glückwunsch an alle
Leute die den noch abstauben konnten ich
glaube auch also als backfan und Sally
Fan wenn man sich den bestellt man
glaube ich mit jedem Türchen komplett
zufrieden in Türchen Nummer drei haben
schnell Stern Tülle habe ich schon packe
ich in die verlosungsbox halt stopp
wahrscheinlich wird von dem ganzen Zeug
nix in der verlosungsbox landen weil
meine Schwester dieses Video schaut und
mir ganz genau sagt was sie alles davon
haben möchte ich muss jetzt hier auch
mal ein bisschen kritischer sein Okay
sally hat gesagt ich soll ganz ehrlich
sein und die Ehrlichkeit bekommt sie von
mir oh Nummer vier ist schwer haben wir
hier in Crossover haben wir hier
Bonbon was ist hier bauen wir morgen
da fängt es an vielleicht muss ich doch
die Preise nachrechnen
passierte Erdbeeren macht aber in Ihrem
Fall super Sinn denn gerade passierte
Erdbeeren braucht man bei wahrscheinlich
so vielen Kuchen die finde ich das blöd
wenn ihr nicht sehen könnt was ich da so
rausziehen ne oh ja der erste Eindruck
hat getäuscht dieses Päckchen hat sich
beim Rausziehen geöffnet Punkt Abzug das
Türchen Nummer fünf hat sie aber nur
geöffnet weil er war so großes und
schweres drin ist nein wirklich du
packst Brot Nummer 6
ein Türchen Nummer 5 rein also da wird
mein Monk ja so getriggert und hier
gibt's immer wieder ein paar Rabatte
außerdem ist schon für würziges
Roggenmischbrot mit Haferflocken sally
hat natürlich hier eigenes Brot ist
wahrscheinlich mal so durch ihr wo läuft
sie darum durch ihre Fabrikhalle durch
ihre Lager da ist sie so durch die Lage
gelaufen hat gesagt ich will ein Brot
backen warum haben wir eigentlich noch
keine Brotbackmischung Burat können wir
eine Brot Backmischung
produzieren das waren die Geschichte der
Entstehung der Brotbackmischung freu
dich auf die nächsten
Entstehungsgeschichten ich packe aus
Türchen Nummer 6 Nikolaus Nikolaus ist
ein sehr sehr großes Team das ist gar
nicht so groß das ist nur flach dahinter
ist noch was ich meine es ist ein
sehr klein und guck mal hier von
[Musik]
der Sallys Stäbchenprobe natürlich
nicht ein altes s-stäbchen vom Vorabend
um unseren Kuchen zu testen ob der durch
ist nein wir nehmen Sallys Stäbchenprobe
der kuchentester auf einen Kuchen fertig
ist oder nicht findest du mit einer
Stäbchenprobe heraus statt eines
Zahnstochers kannst du diesen Edelstahl
küchentester dabei mittig an der
höchsten Stelle des Kuchens in das
Gepäck stecken und wieder heraus
ist für mich jetzt kein Nikolaus
Geschenk was wäre denn für Nikolaus ich
guck mal ob ich noch Produkte da drin
finde die mich ja für Nikolaus
angesprochen hätten okay wir hatten
jetzt sechs
bis in den anderen Videos schon gesagt
habe ich liebe Beutel
das war so eine gute Idee einen Beutel
in den Kalender rein zu machen also
wirklich toll in den letzten Kalender
habe ich vielleicht gesagt ich habe
genug Beutel und ich brauche nicht noch
mehr aber komm das ist ein Sally speutel
könnt ihr in dem sallybeut böse sein
fragt euch das jetzt mal wirklich nee
also ich meine jetzt meine Schwester
wird sich übelst über diesen Beutel
freuen ich habe halt viele Beute okay
immer wenn ich jetzt ein Beutel im
Kalender hat habe ich gesagt dass ich
viele Beutel habe in Türchen
noch na klar Glitzer Schnee ist doch
klar dass wir ein Beutel gekriegt haben
weil wir so viele tolle oh das ist aber
kein Sandy Produkt oder ist das Zelt das
Handy arbeitet mit denen zusammen ne
sehr gut dann packen wir mal unseren
Glitzer Schnee das ist alles mal rein
haben wir hier eine gute Ordnung ihr
könnt sagen was ihr wollt bis jetzt kann
ich alles wunderbar für meine
Weihnachtsbäckerei gebrauchen Türchen
Nummer 9 das wichtigste Türchen des
Adventskalenders warum wissen wir nicht
ich habe es einfach so entschieden eine
Teigkarte darüber wird sich Timo freuen
der ist nämlich total der Pizzabäcker
geworden eine Teigkarte was rede ich da
drei teigkarten
boah nee das braucht er tatsächlich also
weil erst so von der Pizzabäcker
geworden und immer wenn er zu Gebäck hat
und so dann ja ist das halt sehr
praktisch aber man kann damit nicht nur
Teig trennen sondern auch z.B hier die
Ränder machen mit den aufsetzen in der
Nummer 10 bist findet sich Tonka Paste
und jetzt bin ich mal so gespannt die
Tonka Paste riecht beim perfekten Dinner
auf VOX da diese Kochsendung da machen
die immer irgendwas mit Tonka weil die
nicht Vanille benutzen wollen
[Musik]
oh so riechtonka was ganz eigenes also
wie würde man den Geruch von Vanille
beschreiben es riecht nach Vanille
Fans sieht es sehr machen aber jetzt
geöffnet als nächstes kommt die Nummer
11 oh da ist sie Runde Ausstecher na
klar ich muss ehrlich gesagt mein back
Content langsam auch auf YouTube wieder
aufleben lassen wenn ich das alles sehe
frage ich mich warum habe ich jemals
aufgehört Torten zu machen erinnert sich
jemand von euch noch an meine
einhorntorte ich habe so viele Tiere wie
viele hast du die war super und ich habe
drei Tage an der gearbeitet aber ich
will auch wieder backen ich brauche
einen Kameramann hundeback Ausstecher
von Teig von Norm Marzipan
modellierschokolade Knete ja super ich
sag's euch Jan wenn die Adventskalender
vorbei sind wenn vloggen ist vorbei ist
und dann der Januar kommt dann mache ich
Sally wieder Konkurrenz kann sie sich
aber warm einpacken also auch weil es
Januars und das kalt draußen ist also
packe ich bitte trotzdem ein Sally weil
das kann halt echt gefährlich sein aber
auch so pack dich warm
zieh Dich pack dich zieh dich warm an
zieh dich warm anziehen neuer Sheriff in
der Stadt Halbzeit macht so Spaß wenn
ich keine Preise raushole gucken muss
jawollo das ist mir leer gegangen
backtrennspray Timo backtrennspray geil
ne
doch Duschen kannst
okay da schaut sich das einmal an die
hat sich die Pinguine
gerade vorgestellt wie ich dann im
Januar mein back Content wieder aufleben
lasse aber nur Sally Produkte ich werde
wahrscheinlich einfach eine laufendes
Handy Werbetafel werden also freddy ist
es ja jetzt schon aber ich schließe mich
gerne an
sind die toll und natürlich steht selbst
auf dem blöden selbst auf den hier steht
Sally drauf hurat die ähm die silbernen
Löffel die sind schon mega cool ne aber
kann da auch mein Name draufstehen
ich meine das Metall und das ist schon
auf wenn ich da jetzt auch noch mal
Murat ich will wirklich gerne das war
mein Name drauf steht Sallys Messlöffel
14 Murat ich
wirklich ein Schneebesen haben aber
Sally es gibt wirklich viele Schneebesen
nee Murat ich möchte wirklich meinen
eigenen schneeßen haben der ist
irgendwie anders als andere Profi
Schneebesen
Murat kann da auch auf dem Metall meinen
Namen draufstehen ja Sally da kann auch
dein Name drauf stehen ich weiß nicht
was das bringen soll es sieht ziemlich
fancy aus dass das immer so
abgeschlagen flach von den Seiten ist
der Griff ist so ein Gummi 25%
schnelleres aufschlagen durch gezackte
Drahtschlaufen wow
aufpassen klar Sallys Olivenöl es
wundert mich das in dem Glas nicht äh
Sally eingraviert wurde natives Natur
Olivenöl extra früh Ernte kaltgepresst
klar so leben hey Kinder hier ist wieder
eure malwanne wollt ihr wissen was die
Sally noch so alles in ihrem Lager hat
na dann gucken wir mal rein na klar das
Brot Nummer 1 Sally das hätte in Türchen
Nummer eins gemacht das sind jetzt zwar
nicht ein gutes Nikolaus aber
ihr könnt euch mit diesen Kalender Brot
backen und dann noch das Olivenöl und
dann da rein Dippen for Mischung für
Weizen Roggenbrot mit afrikanischen
Hirsesorten und dann die Zubereitung das
Gute ist wir haben so einen gusseisernen
Topf und da wird das Brot richtig gut
drin krass irgendwie hatte ich nur Kram
erwartet aber sie hat ja so ein großes
Angebot natürlich kann sie auch mal ein
Brot reinmachen sie hat
einen großen
Nummer 16
hau weiter rein ich will dass Samira und
Ela so ein krankes Empire Erben ich
liebe die ich habe die sogar gerade zu
Hause Manuka Honig ist sehr gut für den
Hals ein bisschen random muss ich leider
zugeben es tut mir leid ein bisschen
random unser Adventskalender ist
volljährig und darf jetzt trinken da
haben wir sie gerade noch im Katalog
gesehen die Strukturen Stempel und was
wir nicht alles für tolle Strukturen
machen können eine Wand sowas ähm
Herzchen mit Dings der dies mag ich
damit kann man so coole bouji
hochzeitstortenartige Torten machen das
ist halt so eine Struktur dann nimmst du
deine Torte mal ja es gibt so ich denke
mal das sind so die beliebtesten
Strukturen das wundert mich die
Verarbeitung wirkt so als ob das kein
Sally Produkt wäre also weil die anderen
Sachen die sind alle so bis zum
kleinsten Teil hochwertig die auch die
sind jetzt nicht Dings aber irgendwie
macht man so einen kleinen Unterschied
ihren eigenen Tee Murat kann ich bitte
mein Gesicht auf dem Tee haben danke 20
stimmt das ist
krass wie das nachah es ist Rose stimmt
die hat ja auch mit so Hosen Wasser was
kann die Frau eigentlich nicht also Rose
ist leider nicht so ganz mein Duft aber
es riecht so intensiv wenn man sich
damit die Hände wäscht dann riecht man
doch drei Stunden danach riecht so nach
richtig frisch gewaschener Bettwäsche
in 20 Jahren irgendwie ging das so
schnell vorbei jetzt ziemlich in der
thematischen Reise Handcreme Rose auch
von der Marke Saliha ich hoffe ich
spreche das richtig aus ich werde das
jetzt nicht auspacken weil ihr wisst ich
habe einfach viel zu viele Handcremes
weil ich wette meine Schwester hat sich
darüber sehr freuen 22 sind wir jetzt
thematisch ganz weg gebacken natürlich
okay
diese Liebe zwischen den beiden das das
kann ich auch also meine Stories sind
voll mit Sally und den Hits in den
Geschmacksrichtungen Vanille Tonkabohne
Himbeere und Waldfrucht Tonkabohne die
gelb auch Komma jetzt kann ich sogar
Tonkabohnen so sieht der kleine Freund
aus
okay
Tonkabohne mit mega interessant und
lecker das ist so komisch hities mit
einem Geschmack wie Vanille oder
Tonkabohne zu essen normalerweise bin
ich hübsches gegessen habe ich das
Gefühl die hatten viel mehr Säure die
haben so ein richtig zarten Geschmack
denkt einfach noch ein Vanille 23 noch
ein Snack jetzt habe ich Lust bekommen
zu essen vorletzt warte mal
23 24
also bis Weihnachten durch ist gibt's
jeden Tag ein Türchen
Handcreme Lavendels ah da wiederholt
sich die Handcreme haben wir jetzt schon
eine gehabt aber lavendel ist bestimmt
richtig geil ich dachte sie ist nur im
rosengeschäft eingestiegen warum hat sie
dann plötzlich auch noch Lavendel
jetzt haben wir das 24 Türchen es ist
nicht das letzte Türchen aber es ist
Heiligabend und wir gehen zu unserem
Adventskalender haben die beste
sally-zeit unseres Lebens gehabt und
jetzt ist was drin ein Gutschein oh da
muss ich vorsichtig sein ein 25 € waren
Gutschein für Sallys
krass ja gut jetzt heftig noch ein
Gutschein ich habe jetzt zwei Gutscheine
ich verstehe es nicht für Sallys Shop
und das ist auch für sallyshop.de also
das ist ein 25 € Gutschein also 25 €
Wert ist da drauf dann hat man hier noch
einmal 25 € Gutschein ab einem Warenwert
von 75 € im Warenkorb und dann gibt's
noch mal Hot Chocolate also das ist gut
krass 50 € insgesamt ist noch mal heftig
aber es geht noch weiter Leute erster
Weihnachtstag der 25 und da befindet
sich scheuern ohne kratzen
oh mein Gott ist das geil das Handy das
war nicht dein Intention aber es ist
perfekt für asmr ah haben wir hier so
ein kleines placement von kochblume die
haben sich wahrscheinlich einen Platz
rein kaufen dürfen das gammelt halt
nicht rum weißt du das kannst du hier
schön wieder verwenden in die
Spülmaschine packen einen Schwamm zum
sauber machen ist aber auch gut für den
gut platziert in einem 25 weil man ja
wenn alles sauber machen muss ne was man
so die Tage davor muss ich gemacht hat
obwohl bei den meisten wird ja erst ab
dem 25 so richtig Weihnachten gefeiert
bei uns ist immer eigentlich 25er schon
die Sache wieder durch wird schön alle
auf der Couch haben gleich einen Kater
Essen noch was tolles was die Mama
gekocht hat obwohl sie auch ein leichten
Kater hat und ich jetzt nie gleich ganz
rausfinden kann die Mütter obwohl sie am
Abend vorher auch Wein getrunken haben
und so aber trotzdem stehen sie am
nächsten Tag da und Kochen noch mal so
ein übelst geiles Essen schaut dann an
Dich Andrea und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Türchen Türchen Nummer 26 es ist
der letzte Weihnachtstag
wir liegt auf unser Couch haben echt
schon viel zu viel gegessen aber da
kommt dann doch noch mal Rouladen um die
Ecke oder eine ganz und dann rollst du
dich so rüber an schon so schwer das
sind so viele Plätzchen gegessen also
rollst du dich so rüber zu deinem
Kalender machst das letzte Türchen auf
und du weißt die Weihnachtszeit damit
vorbei und es ist ein so riecht sauber
also Sally möchte wirklich dass wir am
Ende noch mal hier richtig putzen mit
den letzten zwei Türchen ich glaube die
sind das stand auch da das ist 24 + 2
Türchen ich glaube das sind so die zwei
extra Würstchen so riecht sauber
reinigen neu gedacht Bio alles Reiniger
Geruchskiller Testset überzeuge dich
selbst okay also haben wir hier nochmal
so ein kleines placement von einem
Reiniger sollen sehr toller Reiniger
sein was sagen wir zu diesem Kalender
Sally Produkte aber auch viele Produkte
die ich nicht erwartet habe ihre Pflege
Marke
Tee das Brot also Brot Nummer 6 ist mein
Favorit 25 € im Shop muss ich ein Fazit
ich mag Sally echt gerne aber keine
Ahnung mit diesem Kalender hat sie sich
einfach mal wieder selbst übertroffen er
ist fantastisch
eine Kritik habe ich allerdings dass du
mir beim Auspacken aufgefallen ich habe
das Gefühl es wurde so thematisch
gepackt also erstmal die backsachen dann
kam die pflegesachen dann kam irgendwie
noch die zusätzlichen Produkte ich hätte
das viel gemixter gemacht drei
baggertitel dann kommt eine Handcreme
dann wieder
und dann kommt wieder was anderes dann
wieder backzeug und dann kommt wieder
was anderes es hat sich jetzt sehr so
gestaucht angefühlt wie okay diese
Anzahl an Tagen packt man das aus dann
packt man das aus das hätte glaube ich
besser also wäre einfach ausgewogener
wenn es halt einfach immer durchgemischt
wäre dann würde man glaube ich auch bei
den ersten Türchen wenn man die auspackt
nicht erwarten dass das so weitergeht
wenn man schon vorher auch mal andere
Produkte sieht dann hat man schon so ein
Gefühl für okay was erwartet mich hier
drin aber ansonsten ja ich bin ein
riesen Sally Fan das hast Du toll
gemacht ich brauche dir da gar nichts
sagen ne du bist die Meisterin und ab
Januar schlage ich dich im Backen ich
pack dich warm an ne darauf kannst du
dich auch verlassen bis zum nächsten mal
Leute tschüss Freunde danke für die
Kalender